with parents home now working from home
building home offices and
kids doing school at home building
at-home classrooms basically the whole
house is bananas
okay it's coming out of every corner of
our house
limited space certainly creates clutter
and we want to help okay we have another
viewer
actually her name is talia and she
reached out to us for some
organizational help take a look
hey drew please help this desperate
single mother
i've been home for five months during
this pandemic and i've been saying
every single day that i am going to
clean
this mess and today i was outed
by my kindergartener on her zoom call
why this unorganized desk this
unorganized room
is a nightmare and everyone saw it today
on her first day of school
um talia hello there
hello oh brooklyn
hi sweetheart
oh i've been thinking about you guys a
lot
by the way talia looking good
thank you thank you you're looking
beautiful as well
well thank you i actually dressed this
way for marie kondo i'm not kidding i
went in the closet with lee harris and i
was like what would marie wear
so i'm you know because i'm like her
biggest fan in the world like
intense restraining order level so why
are you finding it
so hard to get organized with
all the things aside that we already
know work from home
school like what is the situation that's
going on in your
shared home office classroom
it is been a mess here
we have been home for eight months
and you would think that that's enough
time to clean this room
it is not clearly it is still like this
and we are both
i am teaching and she is doing school
off of zoom
in this room and it has been a hot mess
yeah to say the least yeah no i've i've
seen the pictures
uh so i know i know what you're up
against
and you know one of the things that i
love about design by drew is i'd like to
show
your desk over here and
something happens talia to everyone
i'm just going to say client because
again my fantasy is that i'm an interior
designer
every client i've worked with on the
show has one very personal item
that they want to make sure we save with
mina it was their family table
with karen it was the painting she
bought with her husband
and now you have this beautiful
plexiglas
desk which i find oh so sexy and i am
really excited because i think you
should keep this desk
and i think when something means
something to you and you know that you
could let the rest go and you wish
wish it away but you want to hold on to
something i think that's spiritually
important so
i want to work with this desk now this
desk looks exactly like my desk at home
i am type a lifestyle and execute like
expectation with type b execution so
one of the things that you need to do is
get bins
all right because obviously a plexiglas
dust has no storage and you can see
everything
so i'm going to say let's do toppers on
your desk
so that you can put the piles and then
get a little p-touch and label it
bills like brooklyn's classwork
and just build them up and then you can
keep the cleanliness and clearness of
your desk
um because let's let's take a look at
what you're dealing with in this in this
space i want to look at the original
picture
that inspired me yeah so
can we get a full frame of that adam
like let's see what we're dealing with
here yeah
exactly so you've got a lot of stuff
piled up in the corner
and you have this open shelf unit next
to you
next to your clear desk and basically
talia here's the deal i couldn't help
myself
all right because i'm just that guy
so that was your room before
but this is your room now
well it will be in a second
there we go perfect
thanks guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thanks guys sorry i probably changed the
q on you
um and sped it up and you guys were like
oh my god
okay let's get to the open doors um
so thanks guys always um so
this is your new office all right this
is a model
of your room what do you think
gorgeous look at that picture i
recognize someone
there is brooklyn's painting now
what i did was i made an a side
for each of you okay that way you guys
can pivot in your swivel chairs
and face each other but
you also can have your backs to each
other
and have your own focal point so you can
get lost in the space
and feel like you're there all alone now
talia something you did that really
helped me
and mina did the same thing and i got to
know karen
i love when the client tells me not only
what
they do like but sometimes even knowing
what they don't like is really helpful
so i looked at some of your references
of rooms that you loved and i noticed
they were all black
white with hints of pink and gray so
that's what i went with here and i put
curtains on your windows because they
were just like
a square box and i wanted to soften the
room
all of your references were light airy
and feminine
but you had like a red wall and piles of
stuff and i was like oh no no no
you want something totally different so
i also got a lot of storage that's
covered up this credenza now by the way
this is
all from cb2 and cb2
is one of my favorite retails on planet
earth they have enough receipts for me
to prove that i am a very loyal customer
and they are giving you
all of this
[Music]
and so because you have your lucite desk
i gave you these vertical shelves which
maximizes story and brings the height of
the room
up and i just noticed that your room
before was almost all squares
so i just wanted to do touches that were
higher
different heights lower change the
dynamics of the window with softening up
i gave brooklyn a black desk with lots
of like rainbow colors because she's
brooklyn what do you think brooklyn
i love it you do because i have to tell
you i think you're the most special
client i've ever gotten to work with and
if you're happy then i really feel good
because
also if you're anything like my
daughters they can't help but be honest
so and then talia i went
just really neutral and feminine and
clean
right now when everything is coming into
our world
and inundating a neutral zen space is
exactly what you need
i cannot thank you both enough this has
been so fun
i hope you enjoy it you certainly
deserve it
[Music]